ciao marine 6 bentornati nel mio canale
girovagando per il web ho trovato dei
video di ragazzi o di ragazze che sono
sorprendentemente identici e dei
personaggi famosi
non avete idea alcuni sono veramente
uguali quindi ho deciso di fare in
questo video per farveli vedere iniziamo
subito del primo personaggio ci sono
tantissime sosia alcune ci assomigliano
di più altre meno
questa ragazzi è identica all'originale
faccio veramente fatica a capire chi se
uno è che sia l'altro c'è ci stiamo
rendendo conto è identica ma il proprio
esteticamente ok il make up
vabbè si può ricreare però cavolo
proprio alle espressioni cioè i
lineamenti sono quei jane austen e se si
è rifatta certe rifatta per diventare
uguale a lei oi nata così gemelle
separate alla nascita
sono sconvolta cioè è emma watson allora
avevo già visto dei suoi tic toc girare
però adesso spulciando sulla sua pagina
ce ne sono alcuni dove magari più
sommati dove veramente i denti gli occhi
sono uguali ed è vestita normale c'è
ovviamente non è vestita da hermione ma
questi dove alla divisa sono spaventosi
se proprio devo andare a trovare
qualcosa il naso è leggermente diverso
perché l'occhio lo sguardo le
sopracciglia tutto anche il capello devo
dire sia il colore che la texture sono
molto molto simili la bocca pure perché
comunque non ha le labbra
particolarmente carnose il naso un po
diverso poi abbiamo si deve girare
youtube live di minor swift vediamo cosa
no vabbè identica
un fermo immagine identica qui è
identica vediamo facciamo la prova del
nome vediamo altri video vedi qua già ci
assomiglia di meno quindi secondo me è
soltanto in quel video che ci assomiglia
politica effettivamente identica qua
giani non trovo questa somiglianza
questa ci assomiglia ancora di più no
vabbè identica cioè il colore degli
occhi e identico il taglio degli occhi
pure passiamo per un attimo agli uomini
con un sosia di leonardo di caprio che è
veramente identico allora vi da fastidio
perché in alcune foto è uguale e in
altre no sennò l'avrei già contattato
non gli avrei detto sposami alla fronte
un po più alta devo dire molto più alta
però la parte dell'occhio delle nozze
questa parte quindi identica la fronte
cioè si poteva farli mostra piantino per
abbassare la fronte così sembra che il
libro il nardò veramente in alcune foto
è uguale poi va beh vedo che ricrea
anche lo stile il mood sa il cappello
indietro quali 90 con la sigaretta qui
c'è ha capito ci sa giocare bene come
noi ragazzi questa forse insieme a dare
una grande e una di quelle che
assomiglia di più al personaggio in
questione è identica katy perry awards
no tra l'altro appena eletto che
praticamente è entrato in una discoteca
non so se a miami e l'hanno scortata
nella zona vip pensando che fosse
effettivamente per katy perry che figata
cioè è effettivamente molto simile allo
stesso colore ai capelli era andata
dallo stesso parrucchiere ha un fisico
pazzesco come quello di vinse quindi
devo dire che ci siamo
riguardo al viso
fammi fare due calcoli la forma del viso
e quella il naso sì più o meno le
assomiglia l'occhio forse un po diverso
lei agli occhi un pochino più allungati
rispetto a beyoncé però nel complesso
devo dire che è una gran bella sosia
allora questa dovrebbe essere la sosia
di rihanna
vediamo adesso quando si gira perché di
spalle cosa no ragazzi è identica
allora stesso colore di occhi stessa
formaggio desse sopracciglia stessa
fronte il naso forse rihanna cena
leggermente più largo ma comunque è
molto simile e le labbra sono identiche
ma comunque nonostante sia senza trucco
mi ricorda rihanna ovviamente non come
me la ricordava nel video precedente
i giochi sono effettivamente molto
simili la forma così allungata il colore
le sopracciglia rimangono uguali anche
il naso devo dire di profilo anche il
naso ci assomiglia 9 a picco i cerchi
stile un po bob marley col cab no vabbè
è uguale
stai scherzando no vabbè sono sciocca
ragazzi identico è identico non ti
aspetta allora o si mette lo scotch è
così o si mette lo scotch o si è rifatto
il non può esser nato così qui si è
vestito proprio come michael quindi t
shirt bianca e chiodo sopra si sta
atteggiando anche un po come lui
facendogli suoi sguardi e devo dire che
è veramente identico si è messo anche il
la matita nera dentro gli occhi e noi
niente uguali
no io io io vi giuro che queste cose da
un lato mi affascina tantissimo dall
altri mettono ansia di tutti immaginarti
cadere una persona prima intenti cat è
come avere un gemello e non saperlo
allora abbiamo finito ma ragazzi fatemi
sapere se vi è piaciuto questa tipologia
di video perché potrebbe esserci una
seconda parte perché vi dico una cosa il
mondo è pieno di sosia di personaggi
famosi quindi se vi va potro fare altri
video su questo argomento
fatelo sapere sotto nei commenti
seguitemi su tutti gli altri social io
vi mando un bacio e adoro